Joe and gay hello and congratulations
I'd like to thank professor Shi Appa so
much for inviting me to your retirement
dinner and for letting me send my love
by video since I'm on vacation the week
of the big event I know you've done a
tremendous amount of good in your years
teaching writing at MIT in addition to
guiding students with their projects
you've demonstrated the way a working
writer lives his craft getting the job
done day after day after day as I should
know because I just checked and found
out that I have been your editor since
1997 and I'm luckier than MIT since as
far as I know you're not planning on
retiring from writing I hope that you
and Gaye are having a wonderful evening
full of people who love and value you
which you completely deserve
congratulations Joe and have a wonderful
retirement
hi Joe I'm really sorry that I can't be
at your retirement dinner and I really
wish that I could be there to give you a
hug and say best wishes on your
retirement since I can't I'll say it
from here Joe you're one of my favorite
writers you're one of my favorite
teachers and you're one of my favorite
people and I feel like it's a great loss
MIT that you're leaving them although
I'm sure that it's going to be great for
you to have more time for your writing
to MIT I'd like to say you guys are
losing a treasure I'm sure you already
know that and the only comfort that you
have is that you still will have Joe's
terrific works I'd recommend that if you
start missing him you go read oh say
graves or none so blind or the Hemingway
hoax or the forever war my very favorite
novel and one that I think about all the
time so you still have those works I'm
sorry you won't have Joe best wishes to
all of you and again I'm really sorry I
couldn't be there
bye Joe
hello Joe it's a great pleasure to be
able to talk to you I'm the occasional
this great celebration I'm I'm proud of
you and as everyone else I want to say
that I had one of the greatest
conversations of my life with you
at the convention which I responded your
query about my well-being with the
sentence well Joe my whole life hurts a
lot less now and and I wanted to mention
the Hemingway hopes which is my favorite
of all your books so beautiful so
complex and yet so clear I cried at the
last line